sometimes people think that when we're
just feeling good that's always a good
thing for business that's not true
that's not true at all because that
feeling good will eventually lead to
feeling bad we want to stay as neutral
as possible what is the real fear that
you have
because people will say oh I don't know
I'm just afraid that's not true in our
brains we know exactly what we're afraid
of so if I put a gun to your head and
said what are you really afraid of
you're going to say you know what I'm
afraid of being rejected or I'm afraid
that someone's going to tell me that I'm
not good enough whatever it is I don't
care what it is it could be anything on
the planet that you want to do great
just call it out and just name it say
this is what I'm afraid of and ask
yourself the question if this actually
happened
how would this serve your life right I
have 30 reasons if it served your life
then you got to ask yourself the
question and if it doesn't happen
how is it actually a negative or a
drawback to your life and what you'll do
inside that you'll realize that the fear
is just manufactured in your head fear
only exists in the future if you take
the emotion away from the future it no
longer has power over you
there he is what's up my man Dr rewire
in the house how you doing man I'm great
brother how are you I love it let's see
the thing behind you is that that's your
logo that said look at that it's a brain
baby look at that I love it
I'm so excited to hop on and dive into
rewiring ourselves because I help
entrepreneurs all day long you can give
them the advice but the advice without
the mindset shift nothing happens like
you can give them the advice of what to
do but that they don't take the action
because they don't have the right
mindset and so
first question for you how do we even
know the things that are holding us back
like how can we even identify them
because they become our just
subconscious pattern how do we figure
out the things that are holding us back
such a great question Evan thanks for
having me here man I really appreciate
it you know the first thing is is look I
always say that you know Consciousness
will never Trump strategy like you can
never out strategize your Consciousness
so what that means is that whatever's
going on in your world whatever blocks
barrier stucks uh obstacles you're in
front of those are the things that
preventing you from going to the next
level all of us are as entrepreneurs
want to grow to the next level whether
it be income impact making a difference
in people's lives that's why we're here
so the first question you're asking is
like how do we know the first question
is this that you're going to listen to
is how do you feel we have to use
feeling as a feedback to let us know
that what are the patterns now you don't
want something just to feel good and you
don't want something to feel bad the
real secret to rewiring is not about
just feeling good it's about can you go
through it through a state of real
balance because can you if you can go
through it with a logical mind you're
using much more of the frontal cortex
rather than the amygdala sometimes
people think that when we're just
feeling good that's always a good thing
for business that's not true that's not
true at all because that feeling good
will eventually lead to feeling bad so
we want to stay as neutral as possible
okay so if I'm
uh if I'm trying to make a big decision
or I'm I'm I'm I'm trying to get my
YouTube channel the 10 million
subscribers or I'm just trying to start
my YouTube channel from scratch and I'm
too afraid to make that first video we
had a woman live on clubhouse last
night's like you can't make my first
video yeah how do you figure out what
the pattern is there it's like
somebody's been wanting to do it for six
months a year three years five years ten
years whatever it is it's like they just
can't get themselves to do the thing and
they're buying their own reasons and
they're logical reasons like they make
sense they're not stupid reasons but how
do we cut through our own BS recognize
hey this is just fear talking and we
need to be rewired like how do we
identify those things real quick so I
did I literally just did a keynote two
weeks ago and I had a lady in the
audience I went into the audience and I
rewired people like you know what I just
go into the audience and Bam should
rewind right on the spot and it took me
four minutes to rewire this exact
pattern she wanted to get into the media
she wanted to get her message out to
more people she wanted to go and share
her message but she's you know she must
have been 55 almost 60 years old but she
was afraid of getting your message the
world so I literally rewired it right on
the spot took four minutes so here's the
questions you want to ask what is the
real fear that you have because people
will say oh I don't know I'm just afraid
that's not true in our brains we know
exactly what we're afraid of so if I put
you to put a gun to your head and said
what are you really afraid of you're
going to say you know what I'm afraid of
being rejected or I'm afraid that
someone's going to tell me that I'm not
good enough or I'm afraid that my that
someone's going to make fun of me
whatever it is I don't care what it is
it could be anything on the planet that
you want to do great just call it out
and just name it say this is what I'm
afraid of and ask yourself the question
if this actually happened how would this
serve your life
right up 30 30 reasons if it served your
life then you got to ask yourself the
question and if it doesn't happen
how is it actually a negative or a
drawback to your life and what you'll do
inside that you'll realize that the fear
is just manufactured in your head
because I've said that for many years is
that fear only exists in the future if
you take the emotion away from the
future it no longer has power over you
how much of this
gets instantly solved versus needs to be
reinforced and reminded and whether it's
working with you ongoing what it's done
like once you see it
so it's like it's like the FedEx logo
once you see the arrow in the middle you
can't unsee it is that basically once
you see it once you bring your brain to
a state of balance it no longer has the
fear to continue to hold on to right our
whole Paradigm of psychology and
neuropsychology has been built on the
amygdala but the work that I'm doing is
not based in the amygdala it's taking
your amygdala to the prefrontal cortex
just my neuro Geeks Who are out there
right so now you look at it and say okay
if I can move forward and you heal the
amygdala you start making decisions from
higher levels of the brain centers
that's what my whole work is designed
around around raising the level of
brainstorms that you're making decisions
around but once you eliminate that fear
not a point where like oh I'm just going
to motivate myself or pump myself up and
you know that's different
this is once it's healed it's no longer
there you'll realize there's just as
many benefits to the fear or just many
drawbacks to it you're going to say
there's really nothing to be afraid of
I'm just going to do it if that's really
what you want to do now here's the big
question right because a lot of times
people will sit and say you know what
I'm too lazy to do this and what I found
is that it's not laziness Evan it's
really what it is it's really something
holding you back the world wants to sit
and say the why you gotta have the why
big enough and you and I have done a lot
of work on this in over the years
I would say okay then I have the Y big
enough that's true at some level
but you and I know that if the Y is big
enough there's still another reason
inside that and the reason you don't do
something is the why not because if I
asked every person on this right now and
said what's your why you tell me your
kids your family your mission your your
goals money whatever it is right and
it's amazing all of it is but the reason
you're not taking action is actually the
why not figure out the why not then the
y takes care of itself I love it it's a
great little perspective shift there
small small tweak makes a huge impact if
I if I had to look at myself uh I think
historically my biggest fear has been
disappointing people yeah so the idea
that I would get on stage or do an event
and that I would I would disappoint them
like I yeah they wouldn't um they
thought of ripping them off or or just
wasting time and that held me back quite
a lot in my early career and now I uh I
I think it's still there so maybe you
can you can unlock it for me uh but it's
I I okay let's go let's do it right now
okay so go to a moment that you proceed
that you you feel that you're you're
going to disappoint who specifically
okay so I'm I'm doing a keynote I'm we
can do this one I'm doing a keynote add
mylet and yeah and uh Andy Priscilla's
event I would say Syndicate these guys
are eight nine figure entrepreneurs who
paid a lot of money like five six
figures to be in the room and uh I don't
know the speakers yeah I land there and
I found out the guy before me is David
Goggins and the guy after me is Peyton
Manning and I'm going to be the guy in
between and I'm having a panic moment
just like oh my God why am I here I
don't belong here okay so at that moment
has it already happened that's happened
yeah yeah it's already happened okay
well let's take something in the future
oh okay
um because that that is no longer a fear
that was a moment the anxiety was a
moment that happened fear exists only in
the future
so so in the future Dr rewire is doing
his world tour
there's a stop in in Toronto Canada yep
and and he's selling out our baseball
stadium we've got 50 000 people in the
arena and he and he kindly asked me to
be on stage as part of the Canadian
content and I'm I'm panicking because I
don't want to let the audience down and
I don't want to let you down okay great
so what if you let them down
okay what if you let the audience down
how does it serve the audience does it
let them know that there's an
opportunity that you know what even the
great Evan Carmichael can have errors
okay what's the benefit of that to them
how does that help them
did they see that I'm human and that
it's okay to make mistakes and how's
that benefit how's that helping them
how's it helping them uh it helps them
have permission to go and take some
action too great how does that help them
does that make more impact into the
world
100 does that make more people are going
to get touched more lives are going to
get touched because of that and more
lives are going to get impacted and
you're actually your work actually helps
get to more people because people get
more permission to do what it is you
want to do rather than just being
perfect
yep can you see that yeah and if you're
perfect on stage and you nail it you
crush it out of the park how does that
hurt the audience
if I'm perfect on stage how does that
hurt the audience
um that's an interesting question okay
um that they won't connect to me because
I'm too perfect and how does that take
away from your message
because the message is about believe and
helping people actually get some kind of
momentum
and so what's a drawback of that to them
the drawback to them is that then they
don't actually go and do anything but
they they attend your event and don't do
anything because I was too perfect and
they don't they don't take any action in
their life yeah and if they don't take
any action they're actually serving the
mission that you actually are on
no no so can you see it there's just as
many benefits to you not doing well and
just as many drawbacks if you didn't
sure right and so there's a balanced
approach now if I ask you the question
is that real fear there
I'm asking very generally of course we
can dive deeper into this and go for 30
minutes deeper into this but just right
now just over this
is the feeling is the fear still there
yeah
um
I don't feel it right now
and that's the thing is because I was
like you right I've been like you know
I'm from Toronto as well right now and I
and I get it right but I used to do with
this anxiety too I used to get anxiety
and we're getting anxious thinking that
we got to do something in the future and
that fear is what that whole anxious
state is but if you realize that there's
just as many benefits and drawbacks just
as many positives or negatives Goods
bads to every event then you realize
that there's nothing to be perfect about
is what I'm trying to say right and I
you may not because there's maybe
something you're not afraid of now at
this very moment but if there's a speech
coming up and you go through this and
realize it it's like oh wait a minute
that may not be there anymore
does that make sense yeah yeah it makes
sense now it has to it has to uh make
feel I guess so
um I'll see I'll see what happens with
my next speech yeah well that's exactly
it right
and so you I mean you've got your book
that that uh talks about this you you've
worked with what 50 000 people or
something going through this process
people worldwide we've done this 500 000
people
is it is it all entrepreneurs is just
anybody who needs to be aware because
we're all messed up we are 72 72 of
entrepreneurs are have some sort of
mental health disorder whether it be
anxiety depression stress Suicidal
Thoughts all these different things
right mental health is really 72
entrepreneurial inside that
um but what I found is this is that
there's there's the world that's in
mental health
and then there's the entrepreneurial
world that says you know what the
entrepreneurial Consciousness says I'm
responsible
and those types of individuals will sit
and say you know what i'm responsible to
get my Solutions responsible to take
care of my mind I'm responsible to take
care of my health my thinking everything
inside of that and those people are
usually the ones that look up for
someone like me to be able to help them
whereas someone who's a little bit more
like you know what I got a mental health
thing and I want to in that is looking
for uh more so the idea of medication
some sort of
symptom blocker inside that rather than
getting the core source the root cause
of the issues involved in it now I will
say this Evan we didn't do this right
now but I'm happy to sit down and do it
with you is that if I go back and I go
to the core source at a younger age when
this whole fear of disappointing people
started the whole thing unravels itself
being what I mean it just goes away it
just disappears
the core source of why I am afraid of
disappointing people uh it's got to be
something childhood right I mean it's
going to be related to a childhood space
for sure okay okay and so I mean you
just walk me through a series of
questions are they always
basically the same questions are that
customized and what's that I was just
going along not even really paying
attention to the structure because I
mean the guinea pig so are they are
there a set series of questions you
always ask or is it you you're surfing
and kind of vibing with people
there is a pattern that I'm looking for
different causes of different issues at
different positions inside it so there
are different uh lanes that I take that
I hear where the situation is and I go
down that lane
um so there's a a path not necessarily a
pattern inside that right and once I
find it though then I know the questions
too ask to be able to get us to that
point of removing fear or getting to
gratitude or or willing to get getting
to a place of balance inside the brain
all of that will be different places
inside of it or really finding balance
from different methodologies so
currently as of this weekend actually I
have 95 different paths that I take
and questions that I can rewire to help
people actually get to that place of
balance inside them
um so but I mean there's a lot of
different tools inside of that I use but
it's kind of like Tiger Woods right
taking a golf club
it looks simple
just asking questions but there are so
many mechanics inside of it that people
don't realize that just to replicate
doesn't make sense right there's so many
little things inside it it's the same
thing with doing something like this
there's so many little fine details
inside of them working through to get to
the point where I'm getting people to
get to like gratitude or fear
you've worked with so many entrepreneurs
of all sorts of levels
are there different
things that people need on locks with
when they're at the beginning versus
different stages such a good question
such a great question definitely the
first I would say if you're making zero
to two hundred thousand dollars that's
where you need to learn and there's a
lot of internal barriers in a lot of
different areas right it could be family
this is where really a lot of
entrepreneurs deal with the biggest
emotion that they stay stuck here is
guilt inside this
guilt is the biggest emotion and shame
is the biggest emotion inside this and
there's a lot of areas inside of that
like my education stuff that we do
inside of it like that's pretty much you
know business owners are trying to get
going who are under 200 000 or 500 000
really get stuck in that space once you
get to the point of 500 to about I take
three million you're kind of at this
place where you're kind of making money
you're doing things it's organizational
you're there but you're kind of working
hard you're grinding at that point right
and what I found is that there's a
Consciousness in that grinding that you
think you don't deserve to actually
delegate so the consciousness of
Delegation has to come into play because
you feel you have to do all the work in
up being hard working
once you get to the point of over 3
million above what I found is that the
the entrepreneur starts to say they need
to delegate they need to organize but
then the Consciousness and the rewiring
shifts to leadership
and being valuable as a leader because
all of us started as you know we're not
born leaders I believe that leaders are
created by their neurology so you create
leadership to be able to lead other
people delegate to other people and rise
and continue to build those
relationships after that point that's
kind of my observation over the years I
love it that was great it's fantastic so
thinking at that last level just selfish
but then what are the limitations and
what are the things you're rewiring
people around leadership
number one is are they do they value the
work that they're doing in leadership
right like that's why like our work is
always connected in that sense that
we're talking about impact right leaders
that think about themselves and are in
that narcissistic state of leadership
those are actually people who are just
about themselves they don't actually
grow Beyond it so the number is 10 mil
that you're trying to go beyond right
they're not going to crack that barrier
because they're stuck in about the
narcissism of themselves so the biggest
thing I have to do is get them to become
more balanced in their mission
and make them much more Mission oriented
at that space how they can make a bigger
impact and raise their Consciousness to
a global level making Global Impact
versus just more of a local impact in
National City School
and then if you go all the way down at
the beginning those early early stage
entrepreneurs you said guilt and shame I
think with the first two what are people
guilty and shameful of man this one's
big this one's really big they feel
guilt about being an entrepreneur and
struggling with their family
so they feel that they they want to be
in business they want to go out
especially the female entrepreneurs just
over the years I've just seen this not
that guys don't deal with this but women
struggle with this harder right they're
trying to be an entrepreneur they're
trying to go out and and build a
business and make it in the world in
that business entrepreneurial space but
they're stuck because they've got family
and kids and the responsibilities that
they think they're supposed to navigate
inside that and they have to try and
balance the two when they go build a
business and they're not with their kids
they feel guilty and shameful they're
like oh you know what my business is
preventing me from being a mom or a dad
or you know what they're not going to
build their business because you know
what I want to spend time with my kids
and they haven't figured out how to
delegate all the responsibilities to be
able to grow collectively inside so how
do you work through that somebody's
feeling guilty they're not making money
they're away from their kids and family
how do you rewire that person well
there's several facets to it right but
uh just just keep it simple if it helps
the listeners right whatever you're
doing whatever you're trying to build
your business towards find the benefits
to your children link it to the benefit
to the kids right if you think that you
leaving is going to hurt someone guilt
by definition is that I'm causing
someone more pain than pleasure inside
that's all that's all it means I'm
causing more pain than pleasure to
someone else
and if you think that the child or the
family is heard it because you're not
there then find what's the benefit to
them when you're not there because
reality is look bro as entrepreneurs
we're independent thinkers we got to go
out and do things on our own and you
know what it wasn't because Mommy and
Daddy coddled us to be to stay stuck
it's because they said you know what you
got have be an independent thinker gotta
be a free thinker and give us time to be
by ourselves that's just part of it but
if you went and listed 30 benefits to
your son or to your daughter to your
family of you being at work go and build
a business and then being by themselves
I promise you what you're going to find
is that actually serves them just as
much to be alone away from you rather
than just be with you it teaches them
Independence teaches them how to cook
for themselves teach them how to do
their own dishes do their own laundry
clean up have responsibilities which
makes them independent rather than just
juvenile dependent
a lot of it feels like it's just a
perspective shift
well if it is right our brain is
completely perspective driven our entire
neuroplasticity is driven by perception
the whole thing is
right and Victor Frankel said this many
years ago is that you know that and I'm
paraphrasing it but everything in your
life is based on how you perceive it so
it is a better perception rewiring is a
matter of perception because at the
moment someone has a major traumatic
impact someone can say this is the
greatest thing in my life or this is the
worst thing in my life but if you think
it's in the way rather than on the way
you're now going to hold your brain in
the amygdala but if you see it on the
way you'll move your brain function
towards the prefrontal cortex where you
can think through things
and so it is a matter of perspective
shift and using rewiring those patterns
that have been stuck in this old pattern
of uh perception like my words here
so if I'm stuck and you make the law
what does that actually mean what it
means is that you're going to be very
emotional and reactive and reflexive for
example
you've heard this everyone's kind of
heard this is that like you have these
triggers right like maybe if your mom
says something your dad says something
your husband or wife they say something
you get triggered and you respond these
triggers are not making you think
logically what you're doing is you're
acting based on the old self
right your old patterns of belief and
Bill patterns of uh or what I call a
root experience or a trauma if for
example you're walking around and you
know what you you see a guy with a white
shirt or a white pullover like this and
he hurt someone you're going to now have
this brain Association to White pull
over hurt someone unless we don't go
rewire that pattern you're always going
to have that Association
so you rewire the pattern now you no
longer have that maybe you say white is
good write an association is the cloth
the the collar priest good safe
right that's that's an association that
was the color red it's an association it
doesn't mean stop but everyone says red
it's an association so we we go rewire
all that and then it changes the way
that your physiology will respond
because of that
so we're making a lot of decisions
mostly from our make The Lodges by
default the work you're doing is
bringing us into our prefrontal cortex
actually like analyze and perspective
shift and and weigh the actual potential
outcomes and recognize it it's just
mostly fear does that then
go back to the amygdala and train that
to respond differently no okay so what's
the how does the process work so what
happens is that once it's rewired and
that amygdala no longer has that
emotional tie it's gone it doesn't have
that reflexive action it now moves to
the higher parts of the brain and you
now think through it logically versus as
a reflex right so for example if you
have that trigger and someone says
something to you that triggers you that
normally would piss you off say for
example now that trigger doesn't do it
anymore now you can think through and
say you know what this has no meaning to
me anymore just like you're saying like
disappointing the audience once it has
no meaning anymore you can't respond
your physiology won't respond in a
stressed state where your cortisol goes
up blood pressure goes up heart rate
increases that's all fear mechanism
right that's anxiety
right if you don't have that anymore you
don't function in an anxiety state you
think through it through logic versus
emotion now reflexively reactively
reflex is where you don't think it's
just like oh my God got to respond
whereas reactively is much more
conscious of your decisions you're
making got it so you're neutralizing it
yeah can can you rewire it to be instead
of not negative to neutral but negative
to positive you can
you can but the problem with that is
this is that people think that being
positive is good it's not this is when
you really dive into my work it's really
understanding that it's not just
positive because you have heard this and
I've heard this like tall poppy syndrome
or peeking out in high school right when
you get to the top what happens is your
dopamine levels your serotonin levels
actually have to come back down and the
true state of rewiring is not in a state
of positive expectancy it's in a state
of governance and balance homeostasis
where so other modalities that are out
there they all shouldn't say positive is
good you feel good that's great but
nobody nobody has ever felt good every
single day and what they try to do is
condition themselves to say I'm going to
feel good all the time but what happens
is the body the healing mechanisms in
the body starts to break down because
you can't function there when you look
at the mind and body the way that it
gets governed and balanced is through
homeostasis in a state of balance what
you want your brain to be is much more
zen-like much more balanced rather than
in a positive related State what was the
biggest thing that you had to rewire
like divorce I tell you what it was huge
like I I would love to sit and say that
I I figured all this out because I mean
I did I worked with patients but then I
had to become my own client I went
through a really brutal divorce and I
lost basically everything I had every
every dime I had I had to eat a lemon
for four days and I was like you I've
been like I'd be going on stage just
telling people to to to go out and build
a vision and build a mission but I felt
like such a hypocrite at the time like I
was like I I'm not even I can't even do
it I don't have any money I was away
from my kids and I remember sitting
there and then like I sat there and I I
was asking everyone how do I how do I
change my thinking because I know what's
in my head
and they just say you just change your
beliefs and that's how you do it and it
was about reading books or jumping up
and down I was just like that's not it
so I went and I sat down and I pulled
out all my neuroscience and neuroanatomy
books I said I got to figure out and map
the brain out here in the thought
process and I did that's exactly what I
did I mapped it all out
and I created this exercise and I
realized that I basically had created
this belief that I could have Love or
Money but not both
right through a brutal divorce I created
these associations
and therefore I wasn't making any money
I wasn't making any sales I wasn't
making any income I was away from my
children I was you know smoking
cigarettes drinking like a fish like I
was on the path of what I call
desperation and death
and I had to rewire all of that to
become inspired again awakened again and
who I wasn't realizing all of that was
on the way for me not in the world and
it became my story that led me to to
realize how to do this and help
entrepreneurs just like me who've gone
up and down and realized that it wasn't
just about being up it wasn't just about
being down it's about managing this
thing for fulfillment and back at the
beginning you talked about Mission so
what's what's the mission that uh Dr
Locke is on I want I want to serve a
billion people touch A Billion Lives
before my day is done
through books through media through
conversations like this I have a billion
people I keep track of it and you know
I've been on this hunt for quite a while
inside of it and we're not at a billion
we're you know we're crossing the
million and a half mark right now so
we've got a lot of work to do inside of
it and make sure that we touch lots of
lives through media through education
through empowering people because the
more people that get empowered to really
understand how this thing works and help
this thing hurt work because you'll
never outgrow the consciousness of the
leader we know that but your health will
never outgrow the consciousness of where
you're at and if you don't love your
yourself all of yourself for everything
then what will happen is your business
gets stifled and stagnated there and you
can do all the strategy you want to but
strategy will never Trump what's going
on in here and to me wealth it's not
just to me it's just when I Define
wealth it's about having money but
having your health and fulfillment as a
part of that not just money
and I want to make millions of people
wealthy that's my game I love it man so
when is the World Tour coming to Toronto
they're going to sell at the Skydome and
make it let's do it
I love it man I guess along those lines
you're you're writing your books you're
doing your tours what what are the what
are the main things for people watching
here live or on the on YouTube that you
want like how do they find you what's
the next step you want them to take yeah
you can go to Instagram here and
Instagram you can go to rewirescore.com
and you can actually Define what brain
pattern you're using like on that you'll
actually be able to see what brain
section you're using and it's a
questionnaire it's a it's a process that
you'll be able to analyze and say okay
look I'm using my amygdala or I'm using
my hippocampus or I'm using more of my
prefrontal cortex and you'll look at it
it's all explained in there for you and
you can just take that score the quiz it
takes two two three minutes and you'll
get the answers for yourself and
transparently just if you want then you
can talk to someone on my team if they
want to do a call and get their
blueprint behind it great if they don't
no worries at least you know what you're
doing that's the main thing right as
long as you know that's it you can go
there you can go to chasing successbook
you can go to drreward.com wherever you
want to go there's lots of stuff look up
Dr rewire anywhere and I'm it's all out
there got the great branding I love it
and that first one was rewire score
s-c-o-r-e.com that's right perfect we'll
link that up in the description below on
YouTube awesome man appreciate it dude
thank you for the love the energy The
Vibes the work you're doing the the uh
self-reflection you gave me the the
homework as well that I need to go off
and do appreciate the time and
everything you're doing man absolutely
thank you and thanks for the opportunity
brother appreciate you much love to see
my one-on-one with Tony Robbins check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there there is a
regenerative Revolution that's happening
in medicine right now in Precision
medicine billionaires know about it but
the average person does it what pushed
me over the edge recently is I had some
experiences that really hit me hard